I've got bad news and I've got worse
news the bad news is that the Democrat
Governor of New Jersey believes there is
a 50-50 chance of recession do we need
this budget surplus right now to survive
some difficult days ahead
yeah I think we do uh is the short
answer and you're right the the budget I
signed a couple of months ago had a
surplus of 6.8 billion dollars I think
the budget the year before we got here
was 440 million and by the way on top of
the 6.8 billion we've got another over 5
billion dollars in either a debt
avoidance or a debt defeasants fund and
I I thought the prior conversation that
Joe had on the the prospects of a
recession at about 50 50. that seems
right to me so we don't want to get
caught out New Jersey's been caught out
before uh and we are determined not to
get caught out again our our job is to
make sure we deliver affordability that
we've got enough in the bank for a rainy
day and that we outperform other like
States and those are our obsessions
right now Murphy thinks there's a 50 50
chance of recession that's the bad news
the worst news is that there's actually
a 100 chance of recession because we
have a officially been in a recession
since July 28th because a recession is
defined as two consecutive quarters of
negative GDP growth and were there and
we've been there for a while that's the
bad news and the worst news both of
which add up together to the worst news
of all the Democrats are now out of
options they have no other way to make
themselves at all palatable to the
American people other than to lie and
you can expect those lies to become more
extreme by the day as we approach the
midterm elections I'm Michael Knowles
this is Michael noelstra
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Heather
Thompson who says gotta love when
Catholic colleges won't even let one of
their own speak don't worry Michael we
lutherans always love to have you have a
great time speaking at WL say yes I am
in Wisconsin right now I was at
Wisconsin Lutheran College it was a
great time last night you can catch my
speech over at the Y A F YouTube channel
it was a great deal of fun you know I
really love coming out here to Wisconsin
I love flying all over the country and
talking to people when you want to talk
to people without flying all over the
country you got to check out pure talk
right now head on over to puretalk.com
enter code Knolls Verizon ATT T-Mobile
these guys take way too much of your
money every month for way more data than
you'll ever need which is really
concerning especially given the current
state of our economy no matter what the
left tells you we are in a recession and
it's time to hunker down and start
saving money wherever we can one of the
ways you can do that is by looking at
your current cell phone bill are you
paying for way more data than you need
if so then you should talk to my friends
over at puretalk Pure Talk gives you
Myriad choices so that you can choose
the data plan that is right for you
whether that's two gigs per month or an
unlimited plan with a mobile hotspot by
switching to Pure Talk the average
family of four is saving over 75 bucks
every month customers are realizing they
simply don't need as much data as they
thought plus Pure Talk makes it easy to
find the right plan for you and your
family through a veteran-owned company
with a customer service team based right
here in the US they make the switch
super easy that's always one of the
holdups is you think it's going to be
impossible to switch it won't take you
more than 10 minutes it's well worth it
for those savings join the hundreds of
thousands who are making the switch to
pure talk today plus this month when you
switch to Pure Talk you get one month
for free I love Pure Talk these guys
have been terrific for years they've
been on this show for a really long time
they've never made an offer this big go
to puretalk.com choose your plan enter
code Knowles for this special offer
puretalk.com enter code Knowles to get
your one month free the lies are become
coming more egregious yes politicians
lie yes the Democrats lie in particular
but the lies are becoming more egregious
because if the Democrats had anything
whatsoever to hang their hats on for the
midterm elections they would be focusing
on that but they don't have it they
don't have it on the economy they don't
have it on foreign policy they don't
have it on immigration they don't even
have it on public health which was the
the most favorable issue for them
previously so now they are just lying
about everything you want to see an
example of how they lie this this clip
is going viral and I think actually most
conservatives who are reacting to it are
missing the point of the clip it's Stacy
Abrams denying that when a fetus quote
unquote when a little baby in the womb
gets a heartbeat that that is actually a
heartbeat there is no such thing as a
heartbeat in six weeks it is a
manufactured sound designed to convince
people that men have the right to take
you control of a woman's body and away
when when you go into the doctor's
office and and you hear that little
baby's heartbeat that's not really a
heartbeat that's manufactured that's
what Stacey Abrams is saying and the
conservatives who are watching this are
saying lady you're completely nuts
you're totally making that up that's
ridiculous
actually though it's more Insidious than
that because the way Stacey Abrams is
lying here is the way that Democrats lie
most effectively which is that there is
a little tiny kernel of an almost little
grain of Truth there around which Stacey
Abrams can build a much more powerful
lie and the little tiny little bitty
itty grain of Truth is this when you go
into the doctor's office and you hear
that fetal heartbeat at six weeks
the sound you are hearing is in fact
sort of manufactured the heartbeat is
not manufactured but the sound that you
are hearing sort of is because at that
time
that the heartbeat that your baby has is
not actually audible the heartbeat that
your baby has is is observed by
observing electrical pulses from the
heart but it but she's got a point the
heart that your baby has at that time is
not exactly the same as the heart that
you have right now or the heart that you
will have in 50 years or the heart that
you had when you were five years old
it's true your heart is developing
and your heart your your whole body is
developing from the moment of conception
and your heart is developing from those
very very early weeks onward threat
pregnancy and then throughout the rest
of your life
so
what is happening is the sonogram
technology is interpreting the
electrical pulses in the early stages of
that heart development and making it
sound like a heartbeat but where Stacy
Abrams is wrong is that's that's not
being made up out of whole cloth that's
not being just totally fabricated the
machine is just interpreting those
electrical pulses which are the basis of
the heartbeat
those little electrical pulses that the
machine is interpreting as
that that is what your heartbeat is and
will be for the rest of your life a way
to think of it is when sweet little baby
June comes up to me my little 20 month
old kid
and he comes up to me
and he wants to watch TV sometimes we'll
let him watch a little bit of TV he
really likes this this one random
YouTube channel
which is just a series of clocks it's
called clock TV I don't know the kid is
just obsessed with clocks and so he'll
come up to me and he'll say Daddy
I would like to watch clock TV now I
want to watch that young man's clock
collection so could you please go to the
Apple TV and then turn on YouTube and
then search for clock TV and then click
on that particular video and then we can
watch that together Dead app please
no wait a second that's not what he says
what he actually says is T
right that when my little kid wants to
watch that specific thing because that's
really all he ever wants to watch he
just comes up and he goes T he doesn't
even say TV he can't quite say that yet
so he says T and then I interpret that
to mean
Daddy I want to watch TV and on YouTube
and I want to watch specifically this
Channel on YouTube and specifically this
video and and my interpretation of that
is correct but he is not saying all of
that yet because he's a little itty
bitty baby
the the signal that's coming out
requires some interpretation but that
interpretation is correct in what that
thing is signifying it's the same thing
with your baby's little heartbeat but
Stacy Abrams doesn't want to admit that
she doesn't want to admit that babies
have little heartbeats because she wants
to justify killing them to the tune of
850 000 per year you're seeing this kind
of lying with the way that the libs are
talking obviously about transgenderism
did you see
oh my gosh did you see the Forbes
Women's Summit you could not make this
up the Babylon B could not do a
satirical article about this
Forbes held a Women's Summit
and the Women's Summit invited women's
rights advocates
into online
influencers and all sorts of you know
all sorts of big women and uh one of the
one of the women that the Forbes Women's
Summit invited is a guy named Dylan
Mulvaney who is a guy who thinks that
he's a woman and he's come to some
prominence on Tick Tock for his days of
girlhood series
this this is the guy that they invited
to personify to exemplify the very best
of women
day 6 being a girl and today I'm in
nature
trees I love them
water lakes I love them
heels they're my hiking heels I love
them
Bridges love them
coconut water love it not mad just love
it
wind turbine love it Meadows love them
[Music]
did you
see I'm scared of getting Lyme disease
oh
I gotta get out of here
did you see that
there's a dragon ball oh my God never
again get me out of here love you that's
just what women are like right this man
prancing around in booty shorts with a
little bra on playing up this extremely
fobish face sort of fear of a little bug
and flitting about and throwing himself
on the ground that's just what women are
like right isn't that what women are
like no not at all that's that's not at
all owner like that's what men with a
bizarre sexual fetish are like
there's a there's another he's
explaining what it's like to to be
him he's explaining the the absolute
horror that some people would believe
that he's actually a man
day 62 of being a girl and I have been
misgendered so many times this week and
most commonly it's a follower running up
to me on the street and being like
you're the boy from Tick Tock it's the
boy from Tick Tock and I'm like no it's
the girl from Tick Tock and they always
feel so bad after I correct them and
that's so not my intention it doesn't
hurt my feelings all that much but I
wear all this makeup and sometimes fake
boobs in the hair and it still doesn't
register with people at times and I was
just wondering if there's anything I can
do on my end for you all to see me more
as a girl I know it's not my job I was
just curious
no there's absolutely nothing you can do
could you believe it could you believe
that some people would think that guy is
a man that guy he says look I I dress up
like a Betty Boop caricature of what
some man might think a woman at her most
absolutely absurd
caricature could be and some people
still think that I'm a man could you
imagine that could you possibly imagine
that okay and I know it's not my job to
show people that I'm really a woman but
of course he's not really a woman and
the things he's doing are extremely
absurd and disordered and ridiculous and
we wouldn't tolerate it from any other
person it reminds me of Family Guy that
voice crying out in the Wilderness
Family Guy which explains this
phenomenon excuse me ma'am no porn at
the bar oh it's okay I'm transgender oh
I I had no idea do whatever you want all
the time
I no no it's uh sir you don't understand
I'm allowed to do absolutely anything
whatsoever because I'm saying I'm
transgender and what does society say oh
yes yes of course
this guy who shows up to the Forbes
Women's Summit dressed up like some
ridiculous caricature of a woman and
flitting about and and
mocking women and making a whole mockery
of the concept of Womanhood
how do we deal with this
the way that conservatives are dealing
with this now is we're saying you're
you're not really a woman a boom owned
with facts and logic you have a a strong
jawline sir and you don't have the body
parts of a woman and you're not boom
owned science
but that that's not enough you know what
that guy's gonna say he's going to say f
your science who cares I don't care
about your stupid science take your
science and shove it I'm gonna dress up
like a lady because I say I'm a lady and
you can't stop me who's gonna stop me
and this is where we get to what the
real conservative response has to be who
cares who cares if I'm dressing up like
a woman
me
I care
who's going to stop me from dressing up
like a woman and behaving this way
I guess I guess I can't speak for you
all just speak for myself
me I would verily very happily stop you
from doing that I think that you sir
and all men out there have an obligation
not to behave that way
you have an obligation not to go outside
in little booty shorts and a bra and and
a big silly wig and lipstick and and
pretend to be a woman
you
I care I don't want you to do that I am
willing to wield the force of culture
and standards and norms and the state to
stop you from doing that
that's the conservative response that's
the only way you're going to stop it
you're not going to stop it by winning
some debate on YouTube or tick tock and
you're not going to stop it by showing
someone some statistics and and citing
some stupid data set about chromosomes
okay you're going to win it by pointing
out that whatever bizarre perversions
are going on in this dude's head he has
a duty and an obligation not to express
them certainly not to express them in
public and then the only other way
you're going to win it is by wielding
political power to say no you don't get
to do it
when you go out in public like this
you have you have to be brought to
psychological counseling if you continue
to behave like this you're going to be
committed to an institution this kind of
behavior is obscene I'm thinking of that
shop teacher who showed up to class in
Canada with the gigantic triple Z
prosthetic breasts and the wig on
looking like a complete maniac
the only way you're going to stop it is
if if you have the courage to wield
political power to say no you don't get
to behave like a crazy person why do I
care you know why I care because I live
in society and I don't want my kids to
grow up in this kind of degenerate
society and I don't want to live in this
kind of Bizarro World absurd Society I
want to live in a nice good place with
good true and beautiful things around me
and people acting as they should and
being polite and being normal be normal
come on folks good grief is it so much
to ask
that we live in a society that is normal
because this is becoming normal and I
don't want to live in that normal I
don't want to live in The New Normal
okay I want to live in a
in a good traditional Society it's not
so much to ask I don't think it is so
how do you get to that Society what's
the basis of that Society
the answer is Christianity this was the
topic of my speech last night the speech
was on our far right semi-fascist
radical extreme founding fathers in the
way that our country existed until about
five minutes ago
but the basis of that Society is
Christianity
if you want to have the good normal
society and that Society is slipping
away there's a terrifying report out
it's in all the newspapers here it is in
the Wall Street Journal Christian
majority in the U.S could shrink to
minority by 2070 this is based on a a
new survey from Pew Research Center
shows that nearly a third of people
raised in the Christian faith currently
leave the religion before returning 30
and an additional seven percent do so
after that age if those rates continue
uh Pew projects that 46 percent of
Americans would identify as Christian by
2070 those with no religious affiliation
would stand at about 41 percent
Christianity would no longer be the
majority religion in the U.S
now
some of us fell away from Christianity
long before 30 and then came back there
is a phenomenon of people reverting to
the church
and it is this really weird Trend that's
going on right now and if you're on the
political right you may have noticed it
at the same time that the whole culture
is becoming atheist irreligious
spiritual but not religious man you know
that stuff at the same time that that's
happening you are seeing a major uptick
especially among American political
conservatives in not just Christianity
broadly but in Catholicism and not just
Catholicism broadly but in traditional
Catholicism you know the smells and the
bells and the Latin Mass Shia LaBeouf
saying that he's now converting to
Catholicism because of the Latin mass
and he said he's doing that because he
felt like at the Latin Mass they weren't
trying to sell him a car there's there's
a lot of wisdom in that quote from Shia
LaBeouf
why is this happening
the reason this is happening actually
was predicted by Alexi de tocqueville so
Alexi de tocqueville probably the
greatest Observer of American government
Democracy in America is his famous book
written in the early 19th century and
Alexi de tocqueville predicts in a very
not frequently cited passage from that
book that in America Christianity is
extremely important to the American
character but over time
Americans will either become Catholics
or atheists that's his prediction and it
seems like a crazy prediction because
you say America is a Protestant country
Catholicism is a kind of minority
religion in America that's crazy how
could that how could that happen well
tocqueville doesn't totally explain his
reasoning here but I think the reason is
Americans are going to
look for Authority they're going to look
for what the Catholics call the
magisterium they're going to look for
the Eternal truths that have endured
from
33 A.D all the way up to the present or
they're going to spin off in their kind
of own irreligion because there is no
Authority that they can cling to even if
they have a denomination that they
really like you know some some version
of protestantism they're not going to be
able to ground that in the kind of
historical continuity and Authority that
is is required for a religious group to
persist in the long run
so I think this is why I'm not just
saying this is a Catholic because you
know I'm sort of cheering on that people
are coming back to the Catholic church
I'm just observing this as a trend it's
the very same Trend that tocqueville was
observing and predicting actually in the
19th century but don't forget he gives
two choices he says they're either going
to become Catholic or atheist well
unfortunately at the moment it seems
like the atheists are winning seems like
they're gonna the giving up and actually
tocqueville doesn't say they're going to
become atheists he says they're going to
leave Christianity and that's especially
what you're seeing now it's not even the
people are exactly becoming atheists
they're just becoming weirdos they're
becoming crystals people they're they're
doing all sorts of weird New Age occult
demonic satanic kind of practices
they're like the Biden Administration
appointees they're wearing you know
pentagrams and leather harnesses and
changing their sex or attempting to and
dressing up in all sorts of weird
bizarre occult ways
well I'm just pointing out if you want
that good traditional American society
where people are flourishing and having
a good time and not everyone is being
made miserable and not all the social
science surveys are showing people
getting less and less happy over time
you're going to have to establish your
Society on the basis of something other
than what we currently have currently
since the middle of the 20th century the
basis of society the sort of animating
principle the soul of America as Joe
Biden calls it has been liberalism
public liberalism such that you can
believe whatever you want in the privacy
of your own home you have the freedom to
worship now the freedom to religion the
freedom to worship but in public you've
got to just be totally secular and
liberal
that's not the traditional American
political order the traditional American
political order is really Christian
nationalism is the idea that America is
a nation it's not an Empire it's not a
city-state it's a nation with borders
that's a specific form of physical uh
order for the country and then at the
metaphysical level at the soul level
it's animated by Christianity not
Zoroastrianism not Shintoism not
Confucianism not communism it's animated
by Christianity that's the kind of
spirit of America that's how America was
made great before until very very
recently certain certainly until the
middle of the 20th century since then
we've tried something else that
something else hasn't worked so I think
anybody who wants to restore any kind of
good sort of America
anything resembling a normal flourishing
country whether you're Christian whether
you're Jewish whether you're Muslim
whether you're whatever the the idea
here is that America as America was
being made great as people of all
backgrounds and all religions and
whatever were coming to America the the
basis of America was public Christianity
if you want to make America great again
you've got to get back to that before
it's too late
speaking of authority
Donald Trump is punching back on all of
the FBI doj probes and raids into his
d-class is classified documents they
argue which presented a threat to the
security of the United States and it was
they probably had the nuclear codes and
Trump almost killed us all because of
his closet at Mar-A-Lago Trump is
arguing
that it is not only did he not have the
classified material
not only did he not mishandle classified
material
Trump is arguing that he could
declassify material simply by thinking
about it
is there a process what was your process
today it doesn't have to be a process as
I understand it and you know there's
different people say different things
but as I understand there doesn't have
to be if you're the president of the
United States you could declassify just
by saying it's Declassified even by
thinking about it because you're sending
it to Mar-A-Lago or to wherever you're
sending it and it doesn't have to be a
process there can be a process but there
doesn't have to be you're the president
you make that decision so when you send
it it's Declassified we I Declassified
everything now I declassify things and
we were having a lot of problems with
Nara you know Nara
is a radical left group of people
running that thing and when you send
documents over there I would say there's
a very good chance that a lot of those
documents will never be seen again
there's also a lot of speculation
because of what they did the severity of
the FBI coming in raiding Mar-A-Lago
were they looking for the Hillary
Clinton emails that were deleted but
they are around someplace so Trump is
saying he's making a good observation
he's saying they obviously didn't go
after Hillary this way and Hillary had
not only did she have more urgent
documents con that were contemporary
documents they were documents while she
was Secretary of State not documents
from the past when she was in office as
was the case with Trump but furthermore
he's saying Hillary did not have this
ultimate right to declassify stuff and I
as president did and I didn't have to
follow a procedure and I could
declassify it with a magic wand I could
declassify it by saying these are
Declassified I could declassify
documents simply by thinking these
documents are Declassified
and so what people are going to hear is
ah there's Trump's hyperbole again
there's Mr Trump Mr exaggerator
he's right
he's right
now he has this caveat here he says look
different people have different opinions
and that's true the reason it's still
something of an open debate is because
this has never been brought up before no
one no doj has ever had the audacity
to go after a former president for
mishandling classified documents
plenty of presidents have taken
documents from the White House
most if not all of the modern presidents
have done that doj has never gone after
them and in part this might be because
of the strange historical circumstance
that Trump is not just the former
president he's the current top political
rival to the incumbent president who has
all but said that he's running for
president in 2024. so yes it's a sort of
open question but the answer to that
Quest it's again it's that the liberal
is taking this tiny little grain of
almost tiny little bit of Truth and then
constructing a big lie around it
the answer to that question obviously is
that Trump is right
of course the president can declassify
whatever he wants whenever and however
he wants to do it
otherwise you you have a kind of
inversion of the Constitutional order
otherwise
the president is then
required to get the permission of some
random bureaucrat at the doj
and that is not how our system works
it's certainly not how our system is
supposed to work
the president is not supposed to be
responsible and accountable to some
middling careerist employee at one of
his own agencies in the executive branch
that's insane
of course the president has to have
ultimate declassification Authority
this is just a political hit job on
Trump it's not the only one we mentioned
earlier this week that Leticia James the
Democrat AG in New York who ran for
office on a campaign of taking down
Donald Trump Leticia James is now
bringing suit against Trump for some
fraud in his businesses and she's saying
that Donald Trump exaggerated his wealth
wow breaking news stop the presses
Donald Trump may have at some point or
another exaggerated a little bit
particularly about his health wow no one
ever saw that one coming of course they
did that's part of the guy's whole brand
and even Bill Barr Trump's former
Attorney General who now they seem to
have a pretty Frosty relationship bar
has been very critical of trump at times
Bill Barr has even raised the prospects
that Trump may have broken some law with
the classified documents even Bill Barr
is coming out and saying this probe in
New York this is a total political hit
job
what ultimately persuades me that this
is a political hit job is she grossly
overreaches when she tries to drag the
children into the this yes they've had
roles in the business but this was his
personal financial statement it was
prepared by the CFO
accounting firms were involved in it the
children aren't going to know the
details of that and be able and nor are
they expected in the real world to do
their own due diligence and have it you
know reviewed independently and so uh
this this to me looks like gross
overreach which I think is going to end
up backfiring on them because I think it
will make people sympathetic for Trump
that this is another example of people
piling on because of trump derangements
section this you know this strong desire
to you know to to punish him
so Bill Barr who everyone knows doesn't
exactly love Donald Trump he's saying
this is so ridiculous and of course I've
been saying this for many months now
it is a it is a prosecution in search of
a crime in so many levels going after
Trump at the federal level because of
the election claims going after Trump at
the state level because of the election
claims the New York attorney general
looking into the Trump organization and
Trump's business dealings the FBI
raiding mar-a-laga over the classified
documents it's all just BS it's a
political hit job to attack Donald Trump
because the libs think that he is the
top prospect in 2024 but there is
actually some question about that now
there is a crazy new number out of
Florida a new poll finds that since
January Republicans in Florida
have significantly changed their
presidential preference
and and Ron DeSantis even Rhonda Santos
the governor of Florida was trailing
Trump in Florida pretty significantly
now he's flipped that now DeSantis is
leading Trump in Florida for president
2024.
by the same margin that Trump had been
leading DeSantis at the beginning of the
year
this according to a USA Today Suffolk
University poll on top of that DeSantis
has raised
177.4 million dollars that's more than
any other governor in history and he's
giving a lot of it away he's currying
favor with lots of other Republican
candidates to help them win around the
country
again I still think today if the primary
were held today Trump would most likely
blow it out of the water that's still
where most of the numbers are but the
question has been recently can there be
movement
DeSantis you know he's he's running he's
in the National media all the time is he
does he have the oomph to overtake
Donald Trump this is the very first time
and granted it's it's into Santa's
estate but this is the very first time
that you're seeing this kind of movement
where people might be scratching their
heads and saying wow even if Donald
Trump runs could someone like a Ronda
santis make a credible play for
president and beat him there are a lot
of people who are saying like hey maybe
I'll run I'm going to run even if Trump
runs Pompeo Nikki Haley is doing that
Rhonda Santos has been a little more
subtly suggesting that and going around
and raising money other candidates too
and it's probably BS
probably people are are not going to run
if Trump runs but if you're getting
numbers like this and if DeSantis sees
this kind of movement in a few other
states you might get an actual Primary
in 2024. now we've got a brand new show
coming up tonight on daily wire plus
it's called breakaways with Allison
Williams if you have not heard Allison
was a successful ESPN sideline reporter
when ESPN insisted everyone get the
fauci ouchy she refused why because she
was trying to get pregnant and was
worried about potential side effects of
the vaccine rather than take the risk
she quit
and breakaways Allison sits down with
athletes who took a stand for their
beliefs the first four episodes featured
Jonathan Isaac Nick rolovic Inez Canter
freedom and Dana White those episodes
will be available tonight at 7 pm
Eastern and the remaining four are
coming soon head on over to
dailywaterplus.com right now to become a
member and watch the series tonight
now finally we have arrived at my
absolute favorite time of the week when
I get to hear from you in the mailbag
the mailbag is sponsored by Pure Talk go
to puretalk.com select to plan enter
promo code Knowles to get one month free
without further ado let's hear from The
Voice mailbag
hi Mr Knowles
I live in metro Atlanta with my family
Marjorie Taylor green has gotten a lot
of press here where her stance on a
mission and some other local topics
she no one represents my district I have
moved we live in a Bluer town now and my
husband and I've been discussing how
best to campaign for our Representatives
we feel like having signs in our yard
would put a Target on our property
um and we have the means unwell to
protect ourselves if it came to it but
we obviously don't want undue conflict
what can we and other conservatives do
in a situation like this to stand up for
our beliefs but not become a Target in
blue areas
I want to raise my four-month-old to
stand up for what he believes in but I
also don't want to put him in undue
Danger
thanks you've got to take stock of the
actual danger that you are in
okay so you've got to use your Prudence
here a little bit
if you are in a basically nice community
that is basically normal
but you're you're just afraid because at
the national level the libs are getting
very aggressive and violent then I think
you can feel fine putting the sign up
there then I think it's probably worth
the risk if you're living in a community
where
where people very likely are going to
attack you for this
then I don't think you're under any
obligation to put the sign up you know
we're called to be wise as serpents and
innocent as dubs not the other way
around so I think there are certainly
other ways to support candidates the the
easiest ways with money
well it's not not the easiest way for
everybody but it's the most direct way
campaigns need money in order to win so
if you're in a position to donate money
you can do that you can donate your time
campaigns rely on free work from
volunteers I've been on Plenty of
campaigns with plenty of volunteers and
that that kind of work is invaluable
when you get someone really committed to
the cause making phone calls and
knocking on doors that can be a great
thing that you can do organizing through
Civic associations that can be really
really important so even if you don't
want to go out door to door and open
yourself up you know if you're just or
cold calling random people if you just
want to organize your friends right and
maybe you can have a little hodgepodge
of these things host a fundraiser so you
invite you know your wealthier friends
over give a little bit of money to a
campaign that's one thing you can do as
well you can get involved in some issues
so you get involved at the school board
level right you you get involved at the
the county level or the township level
and you're working on specific issues of
taxation of local ordinances that's a
way then you're not necessarily
supporting a candidate very often at the
local level candidates are nonpartisan
anyway there are ways to do it the
political involvement this is something
the left is really good at it happens
everywhere it's from the very smallest
kind of School Board Race to the
smallest little referendum on a budget
all the way up to president of the
United States so you can get involved
that way and you should err on the side
I think of Courage but but this is why
Prudence is a virtue too okay you are
not under an obligation to put yourself
into danger we know that things are a
little different now than they were 20
years ago the libs are openly calling
for violence against conservatives not
just crazy Libs well there are all crazy
but not just random Fringe Libs we're
talking about Democrat elected officials
we're talking about the vice president
of the United States bailing out rioters
who attack people in the streets and
commit crimes we're talking about staff
members for Joe Biden doing the same
thing we're talking about Hillary saying
don't be civil with Republicans we're
talking about Maxine Waters saying I'd
go attack Republicans go find them where
they are where their children sleep so
that's a situation that means you are
not required to put your family in
danger you've just got to use Prudence
next question
hi Michael this is Brian from Ireland
listening to you in the Czech Republic
I'm a new subscriber I love your show I
was pleased to hear you mention the
European energy crisis yesterday
this is getting pretty bad I have to say
over here and various governments are
now introducing price cups which we know
is not really going to do anything
because it's like stepping on the end of
a hose the water is just going to get
out somewhere else
uh an industry is really worried about
these prices at the moment that they're
just so high that the likes of Steel
manufacturers and all kinds of heavy
industry are just basically shutting
down or are at least going to so my
question really is uh from your slightly
more detached position in America how do
you see this going for Europe over the
winter please to get your thoughts on
this okay thanks bye-bye terribly I'm
sorry to tell you I see this going
terrible play for Europe over the winter
and I this is because obviously Putin
has invaded Ukraine that's the the
direct cause of it but this is also
caused by really stupid Western policies
with regard to Russia and Ukraine and
and with regard to energy for a long
time uh the the thing that no one wants
to say that we're not really supposed to
say but is nevertheless true and very
serious American Statesmen and foreign
policy watchers from George Kennen to
Henry Kissinger to all sorts of people
saw this coming to Michael Knowles saw
this sort of thing coming the West has
been provoking Russia steadily since the
end of the Cold War the West has been
expanding nato in some cases in a way
that's totally normal and understandable
in some cases in a way that is
provocative and Reckless and totally
unnecessary since the end of the Cold
War and the Western involvement in and
after the 2014 coup in Ukraine is
problematic and in in Putin's words in
his speech that launched the War uh
Putin said that this is an unacceptable
security threat that you've got NATO on
the border of Russia now NATO comes in
and says no no we're just a defensive
Alliance you have nothing to worry about
from us uh Russia oh yeah tell that to
Libya oh yeah tell that to Iraq oh yeah
please tell me that NATO is a defensive
Alliance to all the countries that NATO
has invaded again I'm not saying that
NATO was necessarily wrong to invade
those countries in the cases that I
cited you know especially Libya I don't
don't think that was a good idea but I'm
just
I'm just observing a fact NATO has been
proactive as well not just defensive and
so when Putin says it's an unacceptable
security risk to have NATO and Russia to
have NATO on the border of Russia
specifically in Ukraine which is such an
important territory from the national
standpoint of Russia then you've got a
provocation that makes it that at least
makes you understand why Putin considers
this such a big risk furthermore the
Europeans and the Americans especially
the Europeans allowed themselves to get
totally played by Russia in particular
when they dismantled their their energy
industry when Russia very likely funding
environmentalist groups went in and said
hey Europe you've got to get rid of your
gas production hey Europe you've got to
get rid of your oil production hey hey
West more broadly in the name of
stopping the sun monster you've got got
to get rid of the the way that you can
sustain your entire civilization you're
going to get rid of your most most
important energy sectors
what's the effect of that in Europe what
that means is that Europe is just now
reliant on Russian gas and oil Donald
Trump predicted this he said this is a
terrible idea in fact the immediate
cause of the war in Ukraine was the very
fact that Joe Biden took sanctions off
of Russia's Nordstrom 2 Pipeline and
then when Russia was able to uh or
believed it was going to be able to send
oil and gas directly to Europe they
invade Ukraine again this is not just my
own rantings this is this is what the
president of Ukraine Vladimir zielinski
said he said you guys are causing this
by lifting these sanctions and what
happened exactly what we all predicted
so that's the 30 000 foot view of all
the stupid decisions that the West has
made to put themselves in this
vulnerable position what would I do now
the first thing that I would do right
now if I were in making the decisions in
Brussels for Europe
or in the United States is I would ramp
up and I would have done this six months
or a year ago but I would ramp up as
quickly as possible
domestic energy production oil gas dirty
rotten filthy coal just anything you can
to get energy it's going to be a very
very cold winter and I don't think that
we should be sacrificing our poor people
and our elderly people and our
vulnerable people to Mother Gaia you
know in the name of stopping global
warming I think we need to heat our
homes and I think we need to fuel our
civilization especially now if we're
getting into an Ever escalating war with
a nuclear former superpower okay do it
drill baby drill get that energy out
there and if if not I hold the European
leaders responsible next question
hi Michael I would like to get your take
on a personal issue I am seeking your
perspective about a couple with
differences of opinion with some pretty
important topics I will give you an
example of one I am very conservative my
fiance sort of is on some things but
he's indifferent about others I have
conservative values and I use those
values when raising my children
an example would be he sees no harm in
smoking weed from time to time despite
not having done it in 11 years he has
suddenly taken interest in it again we
are in our 30s with two children only
one of whom is biologically mine I
understand young people who might try
different substances I was not one of
them never have been but I have several
friends who have in their younger days
but as a father and a soon-to-be husband
am I asking too much to expect that he
should be more responsible I don't want
marijuana in my house I don't want my
kids finding it I want to set a strong
moral and not to mention healthy
standards for my children because the
world won't give it to them thanks
Michael love the show of course you are
well within your rights to say hey I
don't want drugs in my house even a drug
that we're told is not that big a deal
like marijuana you are absolutely well
within your rights to tell your husband
that and you should tell him to stop
trying to relive his college days and
get with the program and grow up now
some people are going to push back as
always happens when I come after the old
Haitian oregano the old Devil's lettuce
and they'll say Michael pot's not that
big a deal there's no problems it's not
addictive it's really great it cures
cancer at whatever nonsense people say
uh first of all
the claims that marijuana is not
addictive seem to be falling apart
because people do get addicted to it if
not physically certainly psychologically
and it does cause some problems the way
that people consume marijuana these days
leads to Neurosis leads to anxiety leads
to can lead to psychosis it leads to all
sorts of mental problems you don't want
your kids involved in that because at
the very least one disease that
marijuana is definitely linked to is
laying on the couch eating potato chips
itis
one problem that that the old Devil's
lettuce is definitely linked to is
people just becoming big Stoner losers
Who Don't Do Anything and don't want to
get a job and don't don't feel
particularly motivated okay now I'm not
saying that's true for everybody some
people can smoke a smoke a doobie spark
up a jazz cigarette and function
perfectly fine in society but it is a
problem it's a legitimate fear
especially if you got kids in the house
so yeah I think you ought to you want to
bring that up with your husband
and it's it's going to be difficult
obviously there's a little bit of a
values misalignment here as we call it
and so I don't envy the position that
you're in but I I would present it as
not just a sort of nagging or scolding
or moralizing which is saying look
I like you the way you are I don't think
that you're gonna be improved by smoking
the Peruvian parsley I think the only
thing that could happen is you become
more of a loser and I don't think our
kids lives are going to be improved by
having pot in the house and so
regardless of what you think about the
science of marijuana or whatever BS
Stoner you know nonsense you're hearing
uh just just from a personal level honey
would you mind making a little sacrifice
and you know giving up giving up the old
uh California
man I can't think of another pun I've
run out of puns California cumin I don't
know you've got to give it up uh would
you mind just giving it up for me please
honey I'm just asking you to do that
that's what I think I would do
and then I don't know get your get your
husband to smoke normal things like
tobacco all right next question
Mr Knowles as a service Academy graduate
and a military officer the education
skill set of myself and my peers
combined with our patriotism and desire
to serve means that most of us strongly
consider Federal service after the
military
how can we uphold our conservative
values while working for agencies like
the FBI ATF or IRS should we even apply
to work at these institutions or take
our education and skills somewhere else
which could be challenging thank you for
all you do my wife and I have been
considering Catholicism and attending
Mass largely due to your influence
thanks all right I'm so pleased to hear
that yes I am of the opinion that if you
are so inclined and you want to work for
the FBI but you you fear working for the
FBI or you have some hesitation because
the FBI has been largely corrupted by
the libs I would suggest you go do it
anyway the libs are really good at
infiltrating the institutions and taking
political power and then wielding it and
we're not that good at it we kind of
throw our hands in the air and say oh
well it's all ruined never mind give it
up if there is a chance that you think
uh you could do some good there
and and write the ship
I'm all for that
I am all for that I do not think we
should let the perfect get in the way of
the good
thing absolutely get in there if you're
gonna graduate
work at the FBI don't compromise your
morals don't become just a tool for the
libs don't follow the sticks and carrots
that they're going to lay out for you to
to just become one of their puppets but
if you can go in there and hold firm and
stick to what you believe in and make
the country better I love it that's why
I think conservatives should become
teachers that's why I think
conservatives should get out there into
all of these fields and then and then
wield that power do that kind of
unglamorous work of wielding the power
to
push the libs to the sidelines and
actually give us a good country again
okay the rest of the show
is continuing now you know that this is
Friday that means that Mr Ben Davies my
producer has given me five headlines
from the week four are real one is fake
we have to figure out which one the fake
one is also because it's mailbag day I
will be taking more of your mailback
questions like the mailbag questions
that are actually written in in the
old-fashioned mailbag so make sure you
head on over there if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
foreign
[Music]
[Music]